cette semaine micro-trottoir de gérard
pas bio est intitulé curriculum vite
fait vite fait très vite fait en effet
mes interlocuteurs ont brossé un
portrait stupéfiants de personnages
prétendument célèbre est ce que leur
portrait et perdent en authenticité il
le gagne t il voir en pittoresque golf
web
godefroy de bouillon ça vous dit quelque
chose ben d'après sonos est peut-être su
agrémenter les soupes en sachets non le
bouillon sachets non c'est pas le
peintre goya ça vous dit quelque chose
mais non non je vous dis non non on dit
non non non m'aviez dit pourtant vous
connaissiez goya sa soeur oui bien sûr
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait sa soeur au
peintre au doyen est ce qu'elle chante
mais cassis ne commençait déjà bécassine
c'est ma cousine voilà c'est pas le
peintre goya qui a fait ça verdi ça vous
dit quelque chose on lui doit par
exemple
rigoletto même moi quand je me lâche je
mets un pied par terre
ça y est je rigole pourquoi parce que ce
faire le camion et les 24 heures du mans
la moto vous faites le camion
sincèrement oui c'est comment
faites-vous le camion la voie à des
quotas bon je fais juste camions et vous
allez voir après il y aura tout ce
qu'ils sont le camion
ça nous éloigne quand même de verdi
rigoletto tout ça attendez ce n'est pas
fini parce que moi quand je rigole tôt
j'en ai j'en ai beaucoup de bruitages
par exemple moby lines qui démarre pas
un parti seul après vous avez un camion
gmc guy sa nappe avant un rapport avec
verdi rigoletto ça si ça vous fait pas
rigoler ça si tout à fait oui alors on
termine sur votre c'est quoi j'aime ce
qu'il s'écrase le chat
[Musique]
c'est vers 10
le fait de rigoletto a bien entendu
parler dovid d'eau vide jamais d'eau
plate mais pas d'eau vides puisque
celles aux flottes
c'est l'os en arrière avez vous entendu
parler d'albert camus monsieur c'est lui
qui a écrit entre autres l'état astier
l'état de siège
j'ai un perdu en a parlé qu'est ce que
vous en pensez l'état de siège en état
de siège
je parle tout ce qu'il a ce qu'il a
écrit puisqu'il a écrit par exemple il a
écrit laissé l'état de cet endroit aussi
propre
en sortant comme vous l'avez vous
trouvée en rentrant cet endroit c'est à
dire les wc publics où les wc même dans
même dans les établissements cafés où
l'apport s'est cassé albert camus qui a
écrit napoléon bonaparte ça vous dit
quelque chose
monsieur oui l'emportait en tentant de
voler deux rigolos tôt là oui on a parlé
de d'ailleurs mais aussi c'est pas fini
parce qu'à la fin c'est pour terminer
alors c'est comment l'avant alors on
termine
[Musique]